if you've been following the Star Wars
Battlefront 2 saga
you know the loot box and progression
systems have been a complete mess I'm
Tony and this GameSpot news update is
bringing a few changes first up dice
address complaints about players earning
too few credits at the end of a match
everyone will now receive more overall
with top players getting an extra bump
additionally the amount of credits you
can earn from Arcade Mode has been
capped although the new maximum of 1500
is three times what it used to be
finally dice has updated the free loot
crate's you get for logging in each day
these now provide more crafting
materials than before Battlefront 2 is
set to receive a bunch of new stuff this
month including a season of the last
Jedi content despite any changes to the
in-game systems all DLC maps and heroes
will remain free to see how battlefront
2 stacks up against the rest of 2017
keep an eye on GameSpot for our game of
the year coverage in the coming weeks
[Music]